[Music]
we'll be talking about fashion and
prediction with no statistic outright
thank you
hi everyone thanks for being here so
I'll talk about the first
nearest-neighbor prediction let me
adjust this sorry and the question is
whether we can do first nearest neighbor
prediction without trading of the
statistical accuracy so here is a just
basic vanilla nearest neighbor
prediction we have a query point X and
the nearest neighbors of it and usually
let's first take the simple regression
setup in the regression setting okay we
have n data points iid and then Y is
assumed to be in R and then the nearest
neighbor regressor is just the average
of the Y values of the nearest neighbors
of X so I simple eyes that in the case
of classification Y is let's say Y is
just two levels 0 or 1 and then the
nearest neighbor classifier and now is
just the majority of the levels of the
nearest neighbors the interesting thing
is that we can reduce it quickly simply
to regression take the regressor which
is the average and just threshold it so
but this allows us to analyze the risk
of the classifier just through the risk
of the regressor so that's the main
reason why
so the prediction time we all know by
now that there are tones of fast
nearest-neighbor fast nearest neighbor
search algorithms so the question for me
is let's imagine that we use a fast
nearest neighbor search algorithm how
what's the best we could and here the
best we could do would be at least order
K the number of nearest neighbors that
that we need to return right so no
matter which fasteners neighbor search
algorithm we use will be a disorder K
the thing is that usually we think of K
as very small we take up KS 5 or 10 and
such but however for good prediction we
have to think of case very large as
potentially very large growing with the
sample size so think of K in the
thousands and then imagine another
thousand query points right so we all of
a sudden have an expensive potentially
expensive prediction so theoretically
the optimal K turns out to be at least a
root of n we know the details
if K goes to infinity and understand
without infinity
in reality what kill so so I'll show
experiments you will not just be theory
I'll show experiments where you can
compare using very few okay to using
much larger key and you will see that
the accuracy can be dramatically better
and so if you want to have the best
possible accuracy you need potentially
to have a fairly large cake so that's
the keep wantem so the step so now I'll
just say theoretically why so the
statistical performance of Kiernan
usually they just consider the case
again of regression assume that the
dimension of X is a little T and little
D here could be either the LVN dimension
of the the space of the metric dimension
so it could be if X were lying on a
manifold it could be the dimension of
the manifold rather than the ambient
dimension for much of what I'll talk
about I'm assuming a generic metric it's
not necessary that you a euclidean
energy so now suppose this is just a
classical assumption suppose that f is
actually Lipschitz so essentially we
don't want the Y values to change too
fast in small neighborhoods then the
error of FK of the nearest neighbor
predictor can be decomposed into two
terms a variance term 1 over K and a
bias term of this form right the
variance term is intuitive you are just
averaging K neighbors so the variance
will be about 1 over K and this if you
were to minimize this this is minimizing
K at a root of N and so in the end that
sort of Indian that sort of means that
we just cannot do much better than this
root of n at least at what this seems to
be saying if I want to have the best
possible error for for regression and
then you have the same story for for
classification you can to see a similar
bias-variance decomposition and see that
you require about the same sort of K so
for optimal accuracy
we won't pretty we have pretty
we'll need prediction time to be about
this much irrespective of the first
proximity search algorithm use so that's
a key point I like to keep emphasizing
irrespective of the the first nearest
neighbor search procedure so our goal is
this we want to be able to get the
optimal accuracy
yet in prediction time order log n so
reduce it down dramatically to about
order log n why because for for instance
for one year's neighbor prediction we
know that we can do it in about order
log n if the data is properly structured
so for instance it has finite loving
dimension and such things so we know we
can do it in approximate order order log
N and so the hope here is can I do the
same thing but what allowing essentially
K to be of this order
okay so I guess I hope that that is
pretty clear so and okay I'll go back
here and this is for me not just a
theoretical thing I want to be able to
give these guarantees and at the same
time I want the algorithm to work so
it's a really both so the first
prediction with no trade-off how are we
going to achieve this just using very
simple ideas that are there amongst a
lot of the heuristics for that people
use in practice so reduce the data that
a quantization or subsampling so reduce
the data set and then by however while
you reduce the data set you can imagine
right away that your variance the
variance of the predictor goes up so
we've done to some simple variance
correction and it turns out it's
actually so simple the various
correction that will apply it is
actually so simple but works and so
we'll do some simple various correction
and then show that okay now we can do
this thing in a time log N and yet get
exactly the optimal accuracy the optimal
accuracy in terms of the original sample
size not in terms of the
it's a process so we'll consider common
hair snare approaches epsilon
nearest-neighbor
which can also be called a kernel
regression or kernel classification
epsilon nearest neighbor adjust use all
the samples that I've epsilon close to
the query point ok nearest neighbor use
the K closest samples this fixed so
we're not in the classical high
dimensional setting with these changing
if it is greater I'm not yet I suppose
things actually pretty griefers
this regular one will be yeah Trinity
dimension of the data it's not the MPI
dimension necessarily yeah so so think
of D as the the metric dimension the
dimension of the metric space so so the
outline of the talk first I'll talk
about that a quantization nearest
neighbor in terracotta zation how we do
this without a quantization then how we
do this with subsampling and it will
turn out that we actually for that
accommodation we have to restrict
ourselves to epsilon nearest neighbors
and then for subsampling we actually
could do will talk mostly about K
nearest neighbor
so quantization so the requisition we
just want to reduce the data in some
sense using quantizers and the
quantizers for simplicity here i'll
assume that these are points that are
picked within the original data and
these are the quantization point and
then we assign the original data to this
quantization point for a query x once we
get a query x we just pick the
quantizers the conversation points that
are closest to the
and this can be picked in so many ways
either pick the cake recessed
cues or pick all the cues that I need
some ball around so the main issues here
are so a lot of that there are tons of
heuristics of this type the main issues
are which size of what is the
quantization size to be picked and how
do you actually choose the quantization
foot and then how do you use it so those
are the main questions and all the
heuristics vary in the ways they answer
these questions so here are some common
heuristics I'll just call them epsilon
and heuristics so first they just give
some sort of sense of how you should
pick Q so you pick here to have small
size you want it to be small so that of
course so that you have first time and
then you want it to be close to the
excise close to the exit so that you
maintain those to some extent the
accuracy let's say this is the data that
imagine that we are in classification
although everything that are talking
about also holds for regression for
classification I'd like so Y Q now to
every for every of the quantities Asian
point you assign it a label and the
label your Sun is just the average label
of the point assigned to it then you do
regression
okay our classification for the regrets
are here the regressor here can be
viewed simply as the average of the Y
cubes in some form in a ball of radius
epsilon around X and then the answering
classification is that just the trash
holding of that regret regressor
so it's solving the cluster decay means
clustering right off to a kill
it could be sorry I'll be picking the
optimal kill might require a lot of time
so here I'll just make a a key point
what I'm caring about is the prediction
time not the yeah so so here I hear the
simple heuristics the heuristics
actually are fairly simple and we'll
make a few changes
if you click changes to the heuristics
here and so the first challenge is the
following
EQ as an alpha times epsilon Pocky and
an alpha times epsilon cover of the data
so essentially alpha times epsilon net
of the data here I'm assuming that alpha
is between 0 and 1 and what this does
this simple change what this does is it
ties the choice of motivation to the
epsilon that I'm using for the for the
classification of the regression and so
it removes all the the knobs it removes
a soft a lot of the knobs you just now
have a single parameter to to choose
think about fuss
some-something fix I just have to choose
epsilon so in a lot of these things one
thing that I feel like is not discussed
enough is that the parameter epsilon
needs to be need to be chosen
so so now we tie all this together and
then the next thing we do is rather than
the average of the white cubes we'll
just use a weighted average and this is
a step that allows us to maintain the
original various resources so and I'll
say I'll give some quick intuition as to
why this thing works so the intuition is
we are going to try to relate fq so so
defined based on the quanta a quantizer
q2 epsilon and then i'm gonna call it f
epsilon 2 epsilon and then on the end
samples how do you actually build that
epsilon net there is tons of ways of
building epsilon net so you can do it
for for instance through for this first
traversal
so first again let's go back to to these
conditions here pick kill as an as an
alpha times epsilon net the first part
is important in the in the following
sense here first I'm going to suppose
that X Rho the metric space has doping
dimension T and all I mean by that is
that the covering numbers let's say
alpha optional covering number of any
ball behaves like of Manistee
so that that's all the that is meant and
so covering numbers can be related to
packing numbers and so that means right
away that the number of points that fall
in this ball is bounded and become sort
of a constant it's bounded by this
intrinsic dimension intuitively the
further force the points to be there
will be sold so few points in here
that's a good point but for the sake of
analysis I'm using the limit the limit
as R goes to zero it's at least bound
also the behavior on the sample the
behavior on the entire space bounds let
me give you on the sample so so that's
the first thing that so going back to
that there are very few points in here
and see there are very few points in
here we can see right away that I now I
can have fast prediction because the
first nearest neighbor search just has
to return the number of points in here
so that gets the fast prediction part so
now the statistical accuracy part is
will be obtained by relating FQ to F
epsilon and by when I say F epsilon 2 F
order of Epsilon ok so now the covering
part tells me this that the relevant
excise and what I mean by relevant
excise the exercise that are
contributing to the estimate a very
close must be very closely related to X
they must be at most two epsilon away
from X since the cues are epsilon away
and they are an epsilon code so what
that also means the distance from the
query X to the post contributing effect
the bias of the estimator that's what
controls the bias of the estimator what
that means is that the bias of this
estimator will not be much worse so
sorry there should be two here will not
be much worse than the bias of F 2
Epsilon so that relates the bias to
device of the
so next thing is the variance so as long
as we can get the bias and the variance
to be nearly the same as that of F
epsilon we are done so next thing is the
is the variance if you now is this
weighted average of the Y cubes remember
that the Y cues themselves are nothing
more but the average of the Y's assigned
to the Q's right so little and so
literally all we are doing here is
taking the average rather than taking
the average of the Y values in this ball
we are taking the average of these
points all the Y values of these points
and therefore the variance of it would
be about 1 over the number of points
that were contributing to the estimates
as opposed to 1 over min and Q and Q
here is just the number of points
assigned to every Q right rather than 1
over mean of Q which would have been
what we the the best we could show for
if we just use the average so now what's
left here is to show that 1 over some
and Q is actually not too small hey
sorry is that so man Q is actually not
not too small so the number of points
that contributed to the estimate cannot
be too small so the intuition is
actually simple you argue that sum and Q
must be at least larger than the number
of points that fall in a smaller Bowl
why because for all the points all the
original data points that were in this
ball their quantizer must've been in
this bigger bowl so therefore at the
very least some NQ is greater than this
and what that also means is that the
variance of FQ cannot be much worse than
the variance of the F the Arsenal and
then that have been defined on this
small oval
I hope that Solomon says so now it's not
quite the various advice of f epsilon
but it's the variance of F to epsilon
and I'm sorry it's the bias of F to
epsilon and the variance of this other
thing and you can show that those are
very close to the bias and variance of
epsilon and that gives you that you
essentially are getting a rate that is
very similar to the rate of the original
epsilon and then on all the N samples so
the guarantees are as follows assume
assume a fast range search procedure
black box faster and search procedure
for an appropriate choice of epsilon
first we have that F Q or HQ where the
written regression or classification can
be computed in time order log n plus
alpha minus T the order log n is the
time to get to a neighborhood of to get
to find a Q that is close to 2 X and
then find all the cues that are there in
the ball afterwards and in fact what you
have here is sort of the aspect ratio of
the quantization set and that aspect
ratio can be shown to be of the right
order since the quantizers are far from
each other
the excess risk now of fq HQ is about
team order so that's a that just from
all the intuition I gave a second ago so
here is a how it works okay so at least
we got the guarantees that we want and
here is how it works in practice so we
tried it on a lot of different data set
and for varying values of alpha the
quantization parameter and and here is
how much of the original accuracy is
maintained the accuracy with respect to
how do you call that with respect to the
vanilla epsilon n n is maintained and
then here in the second part is the
speed up in time in prediction time and
so we see that the accuracy for various
values of alpha we have nearly the same
accuracy as before but with very
potentially large speed-up one thing I
have to say here quickly is that both
the epsilon and then in the quantization
use fast nearest-neighbor fast range
search procedures and so we are
comparing phi a quantization with fast
my ranch search with no quantization and
fast right search and yet you have all
this speed-up and so just going back a
bit to a choice question so the choice
of FK is not is actually not just a
theoretical thing another thing that we
noticed here quickly is that as alpha
increases as a continuation parameter
increases alpha at sort of as a knob
between a trail of knob between time and
accuracy so as alpha increases the error
goes up but the prediction time goes
down
because you just have fewer and fewer
points in the bomb what I'm comparing
here also another thing that I want to
say is that these are cross validated so
this is under the best choice of epsilon
for the vanilla procedure and under the
best choice of epsilon for the procedure
now the best choice through cross
validation for both and another thing is
that the errors or the the result that I
had earlier when I said for a good
choice of epsilon that choice of epsilon
could actually be made through
cross-validation you still have the same
result so the main downside however
quantization is that computing cube can
be order N squared in the worst case and
so this could be too much and so one
might start thinking about rather than
quantization subsampling which can be
done so much faster also another problem
with the quantization is that I focused
on epsilon and then for a particular
reason it's very it's sort of unclear
how to choose a quantization with those
probably the properties I wanted to
choose a quantization for KN n rather
than for epsilon n n because the way we
tie the quantization to the algorithm is
using the fact that the neighborhood
sizes are fixed but for KN n the
neighborhood sizes are changing over
space so it's sort of harder to know how
to choose the quantization there I tried
for some time then I decided just to go
to subsampling so nearest neighbor
stopped sampling any question here
so the quantization time is actually any
times than the size of cubes oh sorry
time the quantization is n times the
size of key that money could doing safer
this way yeah so yeah it doesn't have to
be exactly N squared but it's still much
that's the one and any other question so
nearest neighbourhood subsampling so top
quickly busts up something so what we'll
do here is a there's here it's not just
heuristics actually there are tons of
very nice theoretical result on
subsampling as it has to do with the
nearest neighbor in fact there is a
whole literature on the so called the
boosted one enhance and so I'll explain
it in a second so here again I have the
original data and then I stop some point
of you if you point and that's my that's
the way I reduce the data so however I'm
going to use a bag of so many sub
samples so Big M sub samples st of size
little m much smaller than n okay so but
many of these sub samples and then the
idea here is that I'm going to do one
nearest neighbor on each of the sub
samples and I'm going to do the one
nearest neighbor in parallel so imagine
that I have n different computers and
each sub sample sitting on a different
computer so that's a bit of a downside
because I have I need to use these many
more resources in order to maintain time
or to get faster but that's sort of the
idea that he can be done in parallel so
now let so this is the query X for every
sub sample I compute the nearest
neighbor the one nearest neighbor
estimate for classic classification
estimate for each sub sample and then
all I do is I take the majority whitey
overall the sub samples
okay so that's why it's called bagging
of one of one and ends I hope the the
procedure is clear I just take a bunch
of subsample one nearest neighbor on
each stop sample and then average the
one year's neighbor balance now there
are these two parameters and and little
m and how do you choose them that's
really the the big problem in practice
how do you choose these two parameters
and Bo and Sam worth beer day at all and
Sam worth had a lot of really nice
analysis of of this how do you choose a
nnm and obviously large m would reduce
variance you want a fairly large and to
reduce variance and then interesting
there is a trade-off on little m on the
sub sample size and small m means richer
subsamples you can imagine that if m the
sub sample size is too large then then
you don't have much they all look the
same they all look the same the variance
is very small but they all look the same
and so you're not really doing much so
little m gives you something richer but
has more more variance and so you don't
want little you don't want the m to be
too small not too large so the optimal
choice they they sort of understood they
sort of other certain conditions they
can show that the optimal choices of
this one of their own amis of this
formative root of m which is good
because you can let the ratio M over and
go to zero as the sample size goes to
infinity and the smaller m the faster
you do so so that's so here is how it
does
on mini-moon we it does better so this
is one of them and this is Kenan other
the best choice of other best choice of
K and sub sample size here is 10% here
at 75% and as a sub sample size goes up
as the intuition I just gave the error
of the beginnin is not that good but
here the error is much better if all for
something smaller if you weren't much
below this the error then start going up
again so it's a result that missing the
various experiments we did that picking
the ratio to be about 10% seem to do it
very well
however this error is not at all close
to the best gain and error and so the
hope for us is can we get it here can we
get it down to here can we maintain the
accuracy so speed up in terms of speed
up we have huge speed ups two to eight
times speed ups throughout depending on
we sub sample size you sorry no they
just uniform
so now can we get the accuracy down to
that of KNN so that's the question and
it turns out that yes you can get the
accuracy down to two that okay and then
if you allow the subsidence of samples
to go to infinity and if I went back
here okay I just had ten subsamples but
maybe I could have let it down let it go
much larger but my problem here is that
every sub sample every sub sample is
only different machine and you don't
want to have to use so many resources so
the question is can we get this such a
high accuracy for small number of sub
samples and yes you can do it again
simply by correcting the variance but
now you want to correct the variance in
each sub sample separately and in fact
you can just correct the variance of
every why the problem that's happening
is that you are using a one nearest
neighbor for the estimate on every on
everything and it has very high parents
so you can correct the variance adapt
what's in a simple way it's simple idea
to correct the variance at that point is
replace the Y values by a previous
nearest neighbor I stilt that won't on
you I hope that makes sense I take my
original T exactly
rather than just using the Y value is
emitted from the point around it but I
can do that in pre-processing time again
do that ahead of time and so it's a very
simple idea
and it also works so here is what we get
right away this is again the beginner
and by just doing this we get close to
the care in an accuracy while
maintaining the time the the speed-up we
get close to the K and occur see with
very few sub-samples so it was
interesting to us that such a simple
idea just works and even explaining why
worse is a takes a few
so the guarantees we have is the
following now we need to assume a bit
more suppose that DX is doubling as a is
doubling so it's just a bound on the
growth of the measure and that Y of Y
the regression function is Lipschitz so
for a good choice of K as a function of
n we have the following we have a
parallel computation time no more than
that of 1 and n so again we're using a
fast one years neighbors search on it
only every one of the computers and and
the parallel computations time is no
more there is nothing to show there it's
no more than that one it actually could
be better because we're using a
subsample the excess error is at most
the optimal accessor in terms of K Plus
this quantity m to the power of M minus
1 over D plus this quantity so because
we can express the error in terms of
both N and the sub sample size we can
also find what the optimal subsample
size is and just as in the earlier
result of Bo and and such we can show
that that you can lettuce of the ratio
of a sub sample size to sample size go
to oh sorry go to 0 go to 0
but but does the octuple m remain the
same or is it now smaller once you've
made the corrections to the to the wild
it remains the same at the order of it
remains the same I was surprised by that
but the order of it remains I said
actually the in hindsight the reason why
the way they prove the way they obtained
earlier the optimal M is by relating the
bagging of 1 NS to Canaan they related
to the order to the risk of Canaan and
the idea actually offline actually I
could explain how how the relation is
done it's actually really neat so so you
have this and but going back to your
question I'll say something more I'm
letting am writing opt here because in a
lot of those work they don't consider
for instance the margin of the
classifier and such things and so here
in this work we consider also the margin
and once you consider the margin then
the optimal M could predict what would
it would depend also on the margin
parameters well schedule and missing
something K was just too for the
denoising phase so how do we correct
variance we just denoise we denote by a
k they can us think a them and so you
just get again by cross-validation with
us probably that's pre-processing that
repose that's reprocessing yet yeah
and so so the intuition is simple
suppose that Big M the number of sub
samples is 1 suppose the number of sub
samples is 1
let s of X be the nearest neighbor of X
in the sub sample s there is a single
sub sample here then the estimate at X
is just the estimate it's just the K
nearest neighbors limit of at s of X
right the next thing is that we know
that the K nearest neighbors to me that
F sub X is close to the base close to
the base up to optimal area good choice
of of K because we have Lipschitz Ness
we also know that the base at s is also
close to at s of X is also close to the
base at X plus essentially the distance
between X and s of X and the distance
between X and s of X is a essentially
vomitus
so that's the gist of the yeah yeah yeah
so here what I mean by the squeak oh is
the is a rate depending on K yeah sorry
not necessarily it's it's a rate
depending on kid I mean if I actually a
checks take the difference and take the
amount on the difference and if the
bound on the difference would be like
100 K plus all right so so that's the
key idea is that okay it suppose that
you have a single sub sample you can do
this relation now you have multiple sub
samples so the variance can only go down
the the good thing here is that there is
already a variance correction here so
you know that the variance of the
original k and n is good but it's but
it's the variance at s of X now you have
this additional bias term and but
everything then works out so so that's
essentially much of what I like to talk
about so the key point is that it is
possible to get the original accuracy of
the vanilla procedure so with no trade
off the nearly or nearly no trade off
not only theoretically but also
experimentally also in practice in the
time of one and n or in the time of fast
one and n or even potentially faster so
there are many open questions one is how
do you integrate all the data structures
so there is a bit of abuse in what we're
doing here forces in the quantization
case we construct this quantization and
then we use a black box first nearest
neighbor search which also often works
by constructing other quantizations and
so maybe we want to integrate
all of this another point is that the
quantization are the subsampling are not
taking Y into account you can imagine
that if there is some region Y where Y
does not change much then maybe I don't
need so many quantizers in that region
so maybe we can design a better
quantization by taking Y into account or
design a better sub sampling
distribution by taking Y property into
our culture is changing yeah that's sort
of what I'm assuming
which is often the case and you might be
able to detect it in data by taking
whatever so then there is simply the
question also of the simple we can ask
the same questions for related methods
such as a kernel kernel life support
vector machines you have the same sort
of problem that if you use a kernel
version of support vector machines you
end up using the vanilla version is too
expensive you and you end up using all
the sample points right and and even if
you are doing first approximations to
the kernel and such things and so can we
also here not have to have a trade-off
there is tons of nice work on on this
problem but that all shows some sort of
trade-off between time and accuracy and
the question is can we actually maintain
the accuracy and get a very nice
trade-off maybe through subsampling or
quantization and such so that will be it
thank you
any more questions yes so just a
question about the the correction for
one nearest neighbor
where you replace the label of it by the
majority or average of its nearest
neighbors so one nearest neighbor by
itself is not consistent but is this
with this suppose you could have just
correct all the labels in this way and
then apply one nearest neighbor would
that be consistent yeah I I suspect so
because I mean essentially that's what
we have here we have consistency not
only consistency we have the rate of the
original KNN right but this is
consistency for a bad version of oh yeah
yeah okay yeah we'll have consistency
from the non back version because in
fact we what we showed is that even for
a single subsample just doing this
correction but here is a point though
here is a big point the assumption that
the distribution is doubling is very
important here the the distribution
being doubling sort of means that there
is a uniform coverage throughout and the
uniform coverage becomes essential
because what you are replacing your
estimate by the nearest neighbor
estimator you want the nearest neighbor
not to be so far and and so it's a
coverage becomes important in here so
for general distributions I don't
I cannot say yes right away but if you
have benign distributions
any more questions
okay northern let thing the speaker gang
for announcements first of all you do